all right we're gonna go ahead and get
started before I give in to the
technical stuff we'll do a little bit of
logistics so we are starting these
things called sessions and we announced
them on Piazza if you didn't if you're
not getting your Piazza stuff definitely
make sure to sign up for Piazza or send
us a note the sessions are designed to
go into the material a little bit deeper
also to discuss something about the
homework they're a structured session as
opposed to an office hour where you can
ask one-on-one questions about the
homework the the sessions are designed
to go a little bit deeper into the
material and they were prompted both
based on some colleagues of mine
feedback of how much students have liked
them in his their other classes as well
as some requests from last year for
opportunities to go deeper into the
material so we've announced these on
Piazza the idea is that you will sign up
for a session they are optional you
don't have to do them we will be giving
1% extra credit for attending them if
you attend a sufficient number of them
the details for that has also been
announced and I think that's - if I've
got that right to the email me I think
that's been announced also on Piazza so
if you go to Piazza there's a number of
different sessions you can sign up for
the point of signing up for them is to
make sure that we have room capacity but
I'm pretty sure we'll be able to
accommodate almost any session you want
to go to the last session will be done
by our zoom and is particularly targeted
at SCPD students but anyone is welcome
to do it the way that we will be keeping
track of whether or not people are going
to sessions or not is we will have a
code that's mentioned inside of the
material and so then you will just write
in that code to indicate your attendance
we will record the last session so that
if for some reason your schedule is such
that you can't attend any of these you
want to participate in session you can
go through the material later and then
record that you attended it by using
that code and we'll be relying on the
Stanford honor code that only people
that are doing this will upload the
codes they may have any question about
sessions and what's gonna what those
involved again they're optional there
way to go deeper into the material some
other people have really liked these
sort of things you can see what you
think it's an experiment
all right any questions about anything
else outside of sessions so homeworks
been released after hours are happening
as usual this week feel free to come
talk to us or use Piazza for any
questions that you have all right we're
gonna go ahead and get started now then
as usual I really appreciate it if you
use your name whenever you're asking a
question or making a comment so today
we're going to finally start to get into
making decisions where we don't have a
model of the world and in particular
we're going to be focusing on model free
control so the things that we're gonna
be covering today is really focusing on
how can an agent start to be making good
decisions when it doesn't know how the
world works and it's not going to be
explicitly constructing a model and
remember a model in this case is going
to be a reward and/or a dynamics model
of the environment so today we're gonna
be looking at methods that do not
involve construction of a dynamics or a
reward model there's just gonna be
directly learning from experience so
before we were mostly talking last time
about well maybe we don't know how the
world works we don't have these explicit
dynamics and reward models but we're
gonna be trying to evaluate a policy
that was provided to us and now we're
gonna be thinking about the real problem
that often comes up in reinforcement
learning which is how should an agent
make decisions when they don't know how
the world works and they still want to
maximize their expected discounted sum
of rewards so when we think about sort
of how good is a policy as soon as we
have information about how good a policy
is then we can start to think about how
do we learn a good policy instead and in
fact when we started off at the very
start of the class we talked about how
you would learn to make good decisions
or how you would compute good decisions
if you were given a model of the world
and so that's what we're going to be
going back to now so in particular now
we can think of starting to get at this
issue of this optimization and
exploration we're still not going to get
into generalization yet this will be
happening soon we've already seen this a
little bit this even came up with
planning but now we're gonna start to
think about how do we explore and how do
we do optimization
so when we think about well I think I'm
just gonna go through more of these as
we start to go into this area so again
we're gonna be thinking about how do we
identify a policy that has a high
expected dust count at some of rewards
there's gonna be delayed consequences
which means as our agent takes actions
that may not see the result of whether
or not those actions were good or bad
for a while and we're gonna start to
think about this exploration aspect okay
so let's start with you know we're these
starts the problems come up and where
people model things when we're thinking
about Markov decision processes and
maybe not building a model so I think
probably one of the first really big
examples of success for doing
reinforcement learning and doing it in
this model freeway was for backgammon
which is roughly 1994 they trained an
agent to play backgammon the board game
I actually using a neural network neural
networks when sort of out of fashion for
probably around 10-15 years and then
came back in the early 90s people were
using neural networks and Jerry to Saro
used it for backgammon and got some very
nice results and that was sort of one of
the first demonstrations of
reinforcement learning in kind of a
larger setting that you could solve
these sort of complicated games many
other get problems can also be modeled
as an MDP weather games or robots or
customer ad selection or invasive
species management and in many of these
cases we don't know the models in it in
advance so what we're gonna be thinking
about today is situations in particular
mostly here where we think about the
model being unknown but if we can sample
it but there are occasionally cases to
where you do know the model but it's
really really expensive so for something
like computational sustainability or
climate modeling you might be able to
write down a good model of the world but
it's really really expensive to run
because actually simulating the climate
is really really complicated really
really hard and even then your model
will probably be impossible but I just I
raised this second point in the sense
that when we mostly think about sort of
learning from the world we think of a
robot like running around in the world
and and that being an expensive thing to
do because robots are taking real time
to do this but you can also think about
agents that are learning to sort of
interact with a simulator where that's
also really caused
all right so what we're going to be
thinking about mostly today is what is
known as on policy learning where we get
direct experience about the world and
then we try to use it to estimate an
evaluative policy from that experience
but we're also going to start to talk
more about off policy learning where we
get data about the world and we use it
to activate alternative ways of doing
things so we can kind of combine
experience from trying out different
things to try to learn about something
we didn't do itself and I'm this third
things really important so I or the
second thing is really important so I'm
just gonna talk about it briefly up here
so imagine you have a case where say
there's only a single state for now but
like you have a state s1 you do a 1 you
stay in s1 then you do a 1 or you're an
s1 you do a to stay an s-1 and then you
do a 2 so you'd like to be able to kind
of combine between these experiences so
you could learn about doing this even
though you've never done that in the
world you've never experienced that full
trajectory but you'd like to be able to
sort of extrapolate from this that prior
experience so this sort of policy would
be an off followed by an off policy
learning because it's different than the
previous policies we've tried we'll go
into that more when we think about Q
learning alright so let's start with
generalized policy iteration okay so if
we go back to policy iteration we talked
about that a couple lectures ago the
policy iteration we originally saw it
when we knew the model of the world so
it was a way for us to compute what was
the right thing to do given right thing
meaning the policy that maximizes our
expected discounted summer of rewards so
how do we do this when we know how the
world works we're given our dynamics and
reward model in that case we initialize
some policy probably randomly so
initializing again would mean that we'd
set PI of s equal to some a for all s
and this is generally probably no miko'
chosen at random and then we did this
policy evaluation procedure where we
first computed the current value of the
policy and then we updated the policy
we took whatever we had and then we did
this sort of one more thing which you
couldn't think of as kind of doing one
more bellman back up where we said okay
we're taking that V PI we're plugging it
in over to here we're using the fact
that we know the dynamics model and we
know the reward model and we're
computing this one step updated PI Prime
and we talked about the fact that when
we do this we actually get monotonic
policy improvement which is sometimes
referred to as the policy improvement
theorem so this procedure when we are
doing it with this guy in this case
where we knew the dynamics model and we
knew the reward model was guaranteed to
always give us a policy that was at
least as good as the previous policy or
better and eventually it was guaranteed
to converge at least in the case where
we have finite states and actions
because there was only a finite number
of policies so in this case there were
only a to the s possible policies so we
don't need to do this whole procedure at
most a to the S times because each time
we're either picking a better policy or
stayed in the same and once you find the
same policy yours you're done so now we
want to do all of this but we don't have
access to the dynamics or reward model
so does anybody have any ideas of how we
might be able to do the same thing now
that we don't know the dynamics or
reward matrix transition probabilities
that you calculate as your suggestion is
well what if we try to i if I interpret
correctly what if we try to basically
estimate a dynamics model in a reward
model from the world and then we could
use this to could still compute your
value function maybe using some of the
methods we saw last time and then you
could do this update this policy
improvement using your estimated
dynamics and reward model of the world
that's a completely reasonable thing to
do and may have any other ideas of what
we could do
yeah named Adam actually into computer
model can I do away with Maury and
ready try to estimate the value of a
particular space see that contest so
just without doing away with the model
we get estimated state in action yes it
was actually yeah so what actually said
is exactly the path we're going to look
about today which is we're gonna focus
on model free control so we're not going
to directly estimate a model today I'm
actually personally very partial to
models they can be very sample efficient
but for today we're not gonna look at
that and we're gonna do exactly what was
just proposed which is we're gonna
compute a cube and if we compute a q
function was just to remember q is
always a function of state in action
we're going to estimate the q function
directly and after we have that then we
can do policy improvement directly using
that q function so how would we do that
so this is Monte Carlo for on policy Q
evaluation and it's gonna look very
similar to Monte Carlo for on policy
value evaluation but we have to make a
couple modifications so before if we
were doing this for V I'm just gonna
write it to kind of contrast so for V we
just had a count of the number of states
now we have a count of the number of
state action pairs before we could just
keep track of G here which can be the
sum of previous rewards we've seen
across all episodes for G of s now we're
gonna do that for s comma a and then now
we're gonna instead of having a value
function we're gonna have a Q PI so
essentially almost everywhere where we
just had s before now we have s comma 8
and then it's gonna look very similar so
we're gonna assume that we're still
provided a policy we can sample an
episode and then we compute GI T for
every single time step and that remember
now is gonna I mean it was before but
we're gonna think about the fact that it
we is also associated with a particular
state and a particular action for that
time step and then for every state
action pair instead of just state visit
in the episode either for every first
time we saw that state action pair or
every time you saw that state action
pair we can always just like before we
can either have first visit or every
visit there we're just going to update
our counts
update our sum of total rewards and then
estimate our key function that's
basically exactly the same as before
except for now we're doing everything
over state action pairs now once we have
that now policy improvement is even
simpler than before so we're given this
estimate of the of the cue function and
now we can just directly take an
argument over it
so we define our new policy to simply be
Arg max of the previous one all right so
does anybody see any problems with doing
this so far for the type of policies
we've been thinking about in this class
so so far we've been thinking about
mostly policies that are all
deterministic which means that for their
mapping from States to actions and we've
been thinking about cases where this is
a deterministic mapping so we always
pick a particular action for a
particular state yeah in the back and
name personally I wasn't what's the
problem we're never exploring which is
correct but what's the problem with not
exploring is that maybe we're only
sample one path I think what he means
more than that is so you can still
sample different paths because your
state space can be stochastic but you're
only going to ever try one action from
one state so you're never gonna learn
about what it would be like if you took
a - instead of a 1 in that state which
means that when you're doing this for
any particular state you'll only see one
corresponding action so the the time
whenever you see state s1 the only time
the only action you'll see will be a 1
or whatever your policy says to do there
which means that you're not gonna have
any information about doing anything
else there which means your policy
improvement is gonna be pretty boring
because you're not gonna get any other
information about things you should be
doing instead so we're gonna have to do
some form of exploration essentially now
we're gonna have to start to have some
sort of stochasticity in our policy or
there it needs to be changing over time
so that we can actually try different
things even from the same state and
learn what to do yes members
access space beforehand great questions
first question is do we know the whole
action space beforehand yeah we're gonna
assume that we do for at least all this
lecture and in general are initially
have high values so the NASA has
computed when it's probably computed
something low so the next time you see
it you would try the other action I just
made a very nice suggestion so um that
relates to how we're initializing the
Q's so one thing you can do which is
what just suggested is you couldn't
initialize your Q function really high
everywhere you can basically do what's
known as optimistic initialization and
that actually can be a really useful
strategy for exploration and if you saw
initialize it in a particular way then
you can have provable guarantees on how
much data you're going to need in order
to converge to the optimal policy so
optimistic initialization is often a
really good thing to do it could be a
little bit careful of how you initialize
things like what those values should be
but generally empirically it's really
good and formally it can be very good
too we're not going to talk about
optimistic initialization today but we
will later in the class or talk about
optimization but my my question is
whatever we're defining the policy we
need to find it in terms of the state
and if the reward that you get from the
state depends on a history you have then
that breaks the Markov assumption and
like even sorry even though the reward
is not Markov that your policy is active
we're defining the policy as if it
worked yes right now is an important
point so your real world may or may not
be Markov all the policies we're talking
about right now is assuming the world is
Markov the policies are only mappings
from current state to action they are
not a function of history so those may
or may not work well because your real
world may or may not be an MDP and if
it's not then you're considering
essentially a restricted policy class
considering only mappings from the
immediate state to the action and if you
what you should do really depends on the
whole history then you might not make
good decisions okay so
so this is sort of how the basic way you
would extend Monte Carlo to be able to
start to estimate queues and once you
have them you could do policy
improvement but now it's clear that we
need to do something in terms of how we
should get gather experience so we can
actually improve when we try to do this
policy improvement because in art now we
don't know how the real dynamics of the
world work so we need to do sort of some
sort of interleaving a policy evaluation
and improvement and we also need to
think about how we're doing this
exploration aspect so in general it
might seem a little bit subtle
so we've already heard one nice
suggestion from like maybe you couldn't
initialize everything optimistically and
maybe that would help you explore it
does but in general it might seem like
it's a little bit hard of how are we
going to get this good estimate of Q pi
because what Q PI does is it says if you
wanted a really good estimate of Q PI of
Si for all s and all a it would say you
kind of need to get to every different
state take every possible action and
then follow PI from then onwards and so
how do I make sure that I visit all of
those things and we're going to talk
about today is sort of a very simple
strategy to make sure that you visit
things which works generally under some
mild conditions about the underlying
process so the really simple idea is to
balance exploration and exploitation by
being random some of the time so let's
imagine that there's a finite number of
actions we're gonna call that
cardinality a here then an Egret II
policy with respect to a state action
value is as follows with probability one
minus Epsilon
you're gonna take the best action
according to your current politics
aren't about state action value function
and else then you're gonna take an
action a with probability epsilon
divided by a
with probability 1 minus Epsilon you
take what you currently think is best
according to your group or your estimate
of the Q function and with probability
epsilon you select one of the other
actions so it's a pretty simple strategy
and the nice thing is that it's still
sufficient but before we do that why
don't we just do a brief example to make
sure that we're on the same page so
let's think about how we would do Monte
Carlo for on policy Q evaluation for our
little Mars rover so now our Mars rover
is going to have two things that can do
instead of and we're gonna be reasoning
more about that so I've written down the
reward function here of saying that if
you take action a1 you get the same
rewards we've been talking about before
which is 1 0 0 0 plus 10 and now I'm
changing it I'm saying well you're
actually and does your rewards do depend
on your state and the action you take
and so the action for a2 is now gonna be
you get zero everywhere then you get a
plus five at the end and gamma is 1 now
let's assume that our current greedy
policy is you take action a1 everywhere
and that we're using an epsilon of 0.5
and we sample a trajectory from an e
greedy policy and again what an annuity
policy means here is I've set epsilon
equal to 0.5 which means that half the
time we're gonna take our current greedy
policy of action a1 and the other half
the time we're gonna either take a1 or
a2 so what that would yield as an
example would be a trajectory such as
state 3 action a1 0 state 2 and now this
is a case where we're sampling randomly
so we flipped a coin we said oh this
time I'm going to be random then I have
to flip a coin again to see whether I'm
taking action a1 or a2 and I took a chi
there I got a reward at 0 and that and
then the rest of trajectory as follows
and my question to you and people you
talked to a neighbor of course is what
is now the Q estimate for all states for
both action a1 an action a2 at the end
of this trajectory using Monte Carlo
estimates so we're doing first visit in
this case
yeah question about the actions we
choose an epsilon phase is important to
women the action on policy phase of
exploration or should we exclude that
action from our actions things that we
like just increase the hands exploring
policy question is whether or not when
you hit a now do something random
whether you should exclude the action
that you would be taking normally if
you're being greedy you could in some
ways that's like just pinion different
epsilon I hear less talking than normal
so does that may have any clarification
questions about this or so um if
everybody's ready to answer so what did
you guys think so you don't have in this
case s3 well you initialize everything
is here to begin with right now so
everything that you did not every state
action and you did not see will remain
zero yeah and then a particular cube as
3 a 1 will be 0 because you saw that
once in the new side it was 0 Q of s to
8 to also be 0 P of S 3 a 1 will be 0
and then the only one that will be
nonzero would be Q of s 1 a 1 which in
this case will be 1 because you decide
once and the reward you got in your side
was one that is one answer is may have a
different answer
so should we come on boolean so all of
the state action claims that they've
seen will be 1 and all other state
action pairs will be 0 and another
answer
so what you're saying would be right for
the TD case what you were saying would
have been right for last week or
yesterday all right on Monday I guess it
may have a third answer could you repeat
what the same the first choice is that
we only update s 1 a 1 the second choice
is that everything that we saw will now
be one and maybe I misunderstood over
there so we're gonna have two different
them we have two vectors now so we have
Q of a 1 and we have Q of a 2 and
they're not going to look identical
so sometimes we take action a 1 and
sometimes we take action a 2 and we can
only update what we saw the returns for
the action we took so what actions did
we take for s3 just a 1 right so that
means for those ones for s3 it's going
to be 1 under for Q of s 3 a 1 so I'll
fill in all the ones that are 0 did we
ever take a 2 and s 3 no so that also
has to be 0 because we didn't ever start
there take action a 2 and get a return
what about for what action do we take
from s2 right so for that one we get a 1
so we basically you distributing your
experience so now if you were to gonna
take a max over those then you would get
the same thing that we saw last time for
Monte Carlo which would be 1 1 1 0 0 0 0
0 to the end but here we're subdividing
our samples so you only get to get an
experience for the action that you
actually took in the state and because
we're in the marching carlo case we'll
see the TV case or q-learning we'll call
it later then we get to add up all the
rewards to the end of the episode so G
here is gonna be the sum over all of
those steps and I didn't specify did
good and we're keeping gamma equal to 1
here just to make all the math just
adding
for us was about whether or not if we
did every visit if anything would change
here excuse me it would not change in
this case because both times when you
visited s3 the summer rewards to the end
of the episode was one so you'd have two
counts of one and then you divide by two
it does it can actually be different but
it's mostly different if you got like a
difference somewhere Awards from then to
the end of the episode yes maybe I
misunderstood so I thought you were
supposed to say that everything was and
I missed that did you say that that was
different for the two actions we have
seen in the project tree r0a yes sorry
about that okay okay okay so now we're
going to show formally that this does
the right thing so we're gonna show
provably that like what we did before
when we were doing policy improvement we
were showing that if you picked a policy
hi I that was generated by being greedy
with respect to your cue function and
that was guaranteed to yield monotonic
improvement and the same thing is going
to be true here too when you do eat
greedy so if you use sort of an e greedy
policy then you can gather data such
that the new policy the new value you
get if you're optimistic with respect to
that or sorry if you're a greedy with
respect to that then you're gonna get a
new better policy okay so let's say that
we have an e Grady policy PI I and then
we're gonna call an Egret policy with
respect to Q PI I which is gonna be PI
plus one so we had a greedy greedy
policy pi i that was doing some amount
of exploration and some amount of
greediness in the past we use that to
gather data we then evaluated that
policy we got this Q PI I and now we're
gonna extract a new policy we're gonna
do policy improvement and we're gonna
show that that's a monatomic improvement
okay so many questions about the what
we're showing
okay so what does this mean so right now
what we're gonna be trying to show is
that this this Q function of PI of s PI
I plus 1 so it's gonna be better than
our previous value at least as good or
better than our previous value of our
old policy PI I so the way we defined
this is now the Q function here is going
to be a sum over our policy of
stochastic so it's PI I plus 1 of the
probability we take an action in a
certain state times Q PI I of Si and
then we're gonna expand that out and
we're gonna redefine it in terms of what
it what it means to be an ingredient an
e greedy policy we either take something
randomly and that's with probably
epsilon and we split our probability
mass across all the actions so that's
how we get this equation so this says
this is the this is the random part so
with probability with probability
Epsilon we take one action one of the
actions and then we would follow that
from that knowledge so that's just Q PI
I of Si and then with probability one
minus Epsilon we're greedy we follow the
best action according to our current q
pi i so now what we're going to do is
we're going to rewrite that the first
term isn't going to change and i'm going
to expand the second
I haven't done anything here I just
multiplied the last term by one but I
expressed the 1 as 1 over epsilon
divided by 1 over Epsilon and now I'm
going to re Express that part so I'm not
going to rewrite the first term plus 1
minus epsilon max over a now when I'm
going to rewrite this as
it's gonna use the fact that whenever we
define our equity policy if you sum over
all actions in a certain state those are
all probabilities of us taking those
actions in that state so it has to sum
to one so I just first to buy it I just
multiply by one in a / - Express me it
is 1 minus epsilon divided by 1 minus
Epsilon then I reassessed the 1 because
this has to equal to 1 because we have
to take some action in a particular
State our policy always has to the
probability of us taking any action
State has to be equal to 1 and then I'm
gonna do that that expression because
we're here is where we would take the
best action so by definition the best
action has to be at least as good as
taking any of the other actions so we're
gonna do the following we're gonna push
that Q inside so that has to be smaller
than what we saw before because
basically we just push the Q inside and
we're no longer taking that max and the
Q values all the Q values that best have
to be equal to the max in other cases
they'll generally be worse ok but then
once we have that we can cancel that one
over epsilon minus 1 over Epsilon what
do we have we have two different terms
here that look very similar we have
let's see meet one mistake in that part
yeah there is an epsilon over a right
there so now I'm gonna pull that out
so I split those terms up the first term
and the third term are identical and one
is subtracted one is added sure that's
clear and so this just ends up becoming
the middle term and that was just the
previous value yeah we changed it to
instead of the sum over all a of Pi I a
given s minus epsilon 2 minus epsilon
over the cardinality K in this case yes
yes so the what we did from the 1 minus
epsilon to the next slide so we had a 1
minus epsilon divided by 1 minus epsilon
and I realized the sum over a PI I of a
given s minus epsilon divided by sum
over a and then if you sum over a that
second term just as epsilon and the
first term is 1 yes can you rhyme your
name
by a sort of fight ok bye I plus 1 which
liner you think yep I'm still not I'm
saying your question which so you're on
the second line is that right or the
first sentence in the first okay PI plus
one is yes yeah greater than the
granular and equals happened because we
push that Q PI we had a max over a Q PI
I of s a we pushed it inside of the Sun
and so that some now no longer includes
a max and so now the the max is always
greater than or equal to any of the
other elements so that's where you got
the the greater than or equal to yeah to
some random so possible actions and then
you end up with more metonic yeah so can
we get some intuition this is sort of
the the algebraic derivation I think
intuitively the idea is that by doing
some a greedy exploration you're gonna
get evidence about some other state
action pairs and then you can use those
to estimate your Q function and that
when you do that then that's also going
to give you a then you then that can
improve your policy cuz then you have
evidence that there's something better
you could do than the current what the
current thing you're doing if you don't
do any exploration you're polit your Q
function wouldn't change from before but
now cuz you're doing exploration then
you can learn about other stuff and then
if it's better you'll see that in your Q
function
so when you think it do the cueball
function it that your exploration is not
as good then you just take the old ones
values yeah
yes so this is now this is saying that
you'll get this monotonic improvement if
you're computing this exactly so that's
an important part so this show so what
this shows here is that if you get a cue
function and there looks like there's
some improvement from some other actions
that you're not taking right now you're
going to shift your policy over towards
focusing on those actions this is
assuming right now in terms of the
monotonic improvement that the cue PI's
have been computed exactly so that's
what we saw when we were doing planning
where we knew what the dynamics model
was in the reward model and we were
using that to compute a value function
so if we were doing in that case we had
the guaranteed monotonic improvement
because we had the exact value of pi and
similarly here if we have the exact
value of q pi then when you do this
improvement then you're guaranteed to be
monotonically improving if you didn't
like if you have just an approximation
of q pi then it may not be monotonic
like let's say you tried another action
once in that state you may have a bad
estimate of how good things are from
that point so this this is an important
aspect and this is going to be really
important when we start to think about
function approximation because we almost
never will have computed q pi I exactly
but if you do like let's say you can
just iterate through this a ton of times
like you're learning that's still a
tabular environment you've converged you
know your q pi is perfect then when you
then do policy improvement you can get a
benefit you can and so there's gonna be
this interesting question of how often
do you improve your policy versus how
much time do you spend evaluating your
current policy yeah maybe that's good
definitely converges to like an optimal
Q public function what is the overall
perfect yeah we'll talk about that
question is great so this is just saying
like one step monotonic improvement what
what's gonna happen in terms of total
conversion so we'll talk about that in
just a second yes remind me name please
slowly a very easy question to answer -
remember right now but what I think of
my I think that's being a function of a
state and he reads it as a function but
action given the state just to sort of
refresh all over my parent like what is
up high and how we define a function now
we're thinking of it is a mapping from
States to actions but it could be a
stochastic function so it can be a
probability distribution over actions so
I can select action a1 with 50%
probability or action 80 with 50%
probability for example from the same
state I mean depends how you want to
implement it like that can start to be
in it but essentially I think of it as
you're in a state and then you have some
probability distribution over actions
you have to sample from that to decide
what action you take the policy the so
what we're doing here when we expanded
this as we said what is the policy for
an action given a state we said with 1
minus epsilon probability we would be
taking this max action so that one and
with epsilon probability we would be
taking one of the actions and so then we
summed over each of the actions we could
take so what we did there is we split
this sum up into the probability of
taking one action and will be the Q
function of that action and the
probability of taking each of the other
actions and what would be the value of
those so it's like our expected value
yeah in the back
it's like when we talked about the
bellman operator reset if you if you got
to the same the same value but you got
before you know you're like you can stop
iterating here would you have to have
tried every action to know that you're
done which is before in policy
improvement if you got to the same
policy you knew you were done you didn't
have to do any more improvement the
question is in this case is it true or
there's some other additional conditions
this is very related question too so why
don't we go into the next part of saying
you know under what conditions are these
gonna converge and converged optimal do
you do you have question before also say
that the only kind of get strict
equality is when epsilon is you want so
we just act purely random with
especially is whether or not there's so
if the policy is random would you get
strict equality here yeah you should get
I mean you can get strict equality
whenever you've converged to like if
your Q function is converged and your
policy is optimal so because if you're
actually totally randomly impact that's
normally often how you start off and
then you want to improve from there
because you're here I mean if you're if
your award isn't uniform some things are
gonna look better than others so even if
you're actually randomly some actions
are gonna have higher rewards than
others and that's gonna be reflected in
your Q function any others before we get
on to convergence in the back what I was
right this should yeah I'm doing I
screwed up the art makes when you
explore doing that do execute the art
next action like yeah like exploration
partner and the tricky part I don't know
what
I know you don't exhibit don't exclude
you don't exclude the arguments action
when you explore you pick all of them if
you wanted to that would be equivalent
to sort of defining it you could do that
but in the simplest version including in
this proof here we assume that when
you're acting randomly you just sample
from any of the states it's often easier
from implementation to okay great
questions let's put that up here as well
okay so this other really great question
that's coming up from several people
here I of okay well what does this mean
over time I've got this monotonic
improvement and what guarantees do we
have so the guarantee is that we have is
if you sample all state action pairs an
infinite number of times and your
behavior policy converges to the greedy
policy so what do I mean by that so the
behavior policy here is sort of what
policy you're using versus what policy
is greedy with respect to your current
cue okay so if you have the case that is
the limit as I goes to infinity of PI a
given s goes to Arg max Q okay with
probability 1 which means that in the
limit you converge to always taking the
greedy action with respect to your Q
function then then your greedy in the
limit of infinite exploration that's
called glee often so that means the
visit all in state action pair is an
infinite number of times but you are
also converging it just gives me in the
limit and to being greedy with respect
to your Q function and there's different
ways to do this a simple way to do it is
to sort of decay your your epsilon or
your your a greedy policy over time so
you can reduce your Epsilon towards zero
it's a rate of like 1 over I for example
that's sufficient it's honest really
they say this is separate than what you
want to do empirically this is just to
sort of show under these conditions then
then we're generally going to be able
show that we're gonna converge to the
optimal policy and optimal value for
Monte Carlo and TV methods so generally
wouldn't think we'll talk about this
again as we talk about some of the other
algorithms generally when you're Glee
and you have some conditions over how
you're learning the cue functions then
you will be guaranteed to converge
Social Policy yes yeah so version is is
this the only way to guarantee yet um
they're sort of interesting different
things that are happening here AB you
could be guaranteed that you're
converging to the optimal cue function
without converging to the optimal policy
so you could keep epsilon really high
and you could get a lot of information
you'd be learning about what the optimal
cue function is but you might not be
following that policy and we'll talk
more about that in in a minute alright
so let's talk a little bit more about
Monte Carlo control and they sort of
given this precursor so if we wanted to
do Monte Carlo online control instead of
just this evaluation we talked about
before we can kind of combine these
ideas of learning the cue function and
doing this improvement at the same time
so we can initialize our cue functions
and our counts in the same way we were
talking about before and then what we
could do is we can construct an e greedy
policy so we greedy policy in this case
is always going to be that with
probability 1 minus epsilon we pick the
Arg max with respect to Q and when
probability epsilon we select an action
here we write it this way
bility epsilon over a we select action a
so always just mixing up between this
random or being greedy so actually like
the optimal action in this case you're
selecting the probability 1 minus
epsilon plus epsilon over the Cornel
every day right okay yeah so this is
several people have asked about this so
essentially you're being greedy with
probability 1 minus epsilon plus epsilon
over a and then the remaining part of
your probability is going to random
exploration because when you're being
random you could also select what's
currently the best action so um it looks
pretty similar to what we saw before
we're gonna sample an episode after we
finished the episode then in this case
I'm defining his first visit note you
could make this every visit visit the
same benefits and restrictions apply
here to what we had before in the sense
that you could either be giving a
slightly more biased estimator if you're
doing every visit but generally you're
gonna be able to use more data it's
gonna be sort of less noisy so in this
case what we're doing is we're just
maintaining counts over state action
pairs and we're updating our Q function
and then after we finish that episode
then we can update our K and our epsilon
in this case we're just using epsilon
equal to 1 over K and then we redefine
our new e greedy policy with respect to
Q and then we get another episode so
that's just sort of Monte Carlo on line
control so why don't we go back to that
Mars rover example so in the Mars rover
example what we had is for this is what
our two Q functions look like so at this
point what would be let's just spend a
minute and say what would be our new
policy if we're at the end of this
episode and and it's fine just write
down ty if there if there are two key
functions that have exactly the same
value for the for the same state for two
different actions and there's just a tie
and you can choose how to break the
break the tie and then also write down
what the new egret e policy is
I'll just take a minute to do that
okay what's our greedy policy
what's our greedy policy for s1 a one
what's our greedy policy for s2 and then
what's our greedy policy for us three
and then what's a visit for everything
else Thai okay and depending on your
implementation you could either always
be you could be there sort of to find
your greedy policy or you would just
like break ties randomly and keep track
of that could constantly be breaking
ties randomly that would probably better
empirically like instead of pre defining
one greedy policy you can probably just
always be cute querying what arc max is
of Q and if you're getting ties just
break them randomly to get more
exploration in so then if we then define
an e greedy policy where K is 3 and our
epsilon is one of our K with what
probability do we follow random so K is
3 epsilon is equal to 1 over there yes
so that would mean that with 1/3
probability we select something random
going 2/3 probability we select the PI
greedy policy and then that would be the
update for that particular episode
so if you do this if you do if you have
greedy in the limit of infinite
exploration Monte Carlo
then you're gonna converge the optimal
state action value so now we're going to
start to talk about TV methods so
similar to what we were seeing for Monte
Carlo there's going to be sort of a
simple analogy that moves us over to GD
so remember for TV what we had before is
we'd have our V PI of s it was equal to
our previous be PI of s plus 1 minus
alpha times
oops alpha times R plus gamma V PI of s
prime minus V PI of s and this was where
we were sampling an expectation because
we're only getting one sample of s Prime
and we were booted wrapping because
we're using our previous estimate of V
PI so that was kind of the two key
aspects of TD learning is that we were
both bootstrapping and sampling and
Monte Carlo we were sampling but not
bootstrapping
and one of the nice aspects of TD
learning is that then we could update it
after every tupple instead of waiting
until the end of the episode so just as
like what we were doing with Monte Carlo
we were kind of up racing all over our
B's with Q's we're gonna do exactly the
same thing here so now we're gonna think
about this or what's often known as
temporal difference methods for control
so what we're gonna do now is we can do
we can estimate the queue PI function
using temporal difference updating with
like an e greedy policy and we can do
Monte Carlo or improvement by setting PI
to an e greedy version of Q PI that
would be one thing we can do there's an
algorithm called sarsa which stands for
a state action reward next state next
action sarsa how does starts our work so
what we do is we initialize our greedy
policy ran
Emily for example we take it action we
observe a reward a next date and then we
take another action and we observe
another rewarded next state and then we
update our cue as follows we say our
previous vet our value of Q for sta T
it's gonna be whatever our previous
value was usually I'm gonna be careful
with this we're not going to index them
with PI anymore
because we sort of have this running
estimate and our policy is going to be
changing too so the the Q function that
we get here is now not just for one
policy but we're going to be averaging
over different samples and we can be
changing how we're acting over time so
it's sthe it's going to be equal to Q of
s T a t plus 1 minus alpha R T plus
gamma Q of s T plus 180 plus 1 minus Q
of s T 80 the important thing about this
equation is that I am plugging in the
actual action that was taken next so you
see you're in a state you do an action
you get a reward you go to a next state
and then you do another action and so
once you know what the next action is
that you've done then you can do this
update and sersa alright so you're
actually plug him in the action that was
taken and then once you have that you
can do policy improvement in the normal
way so you can have s T is equal to
like the e greedy wrapper for that now
so this is a little bit different than
Monte Carlo for two reasons and it's
sort of we're doing these couple updates
we see the state action reward next date
next action tuples and then once we do
those we can update our cue function but
we can do those along the way we don't
have to wait at the end of the episode
and similarly we don't have to wait till
the end of the episode to change how
we're acting in the world so like in the
trajectory that we saw before we saw
some states or multiple times in this
case we could actually be changing our
policy for how we act in those states
during the same episode so if your
episodes are really long this can be
really helpful so in general I think
it's often extremely helpful to update
the policy a lot yes either you could
write it where you put the V in the next
part or not so you can either have it as
one minus alpha times your old value
plus reward plus gamma of your next
thing or you could have it as V plus
alpha times or out so that should be
still an alpha here plus reward for the
minus V so that's either of what myself
if you notice I've made a typo just let
me know yeah about why do we use the
next state action pair you choose and
said if the max q-learning is gonna be
the max we'll see that in about a slide
sources basically updating on policy
that can have generally you want to do
q-learning which is going to be doing
the max sometimes there are some
benefits particularly in cases where you
could have a lot of negative outcomes
that the optimism of being max can end
up
causing your agent to make a lot of bad
decisions early on because it's really
optimistic about what it's what it's
could do instead of what it's actually
doing there's an ice quit walking
example inside of Sutton umberto where
they show that sarsa actually is doing
better in sort of early early stages
early samples compared to queue learning
because sarsa is realistic about what
happens if you take certain actions next
this is a post optimistic and if you're
doing a lot of randomness that means
that starts that can be more realistic
in the early stages but empirically
generally you want to do key learning
and both will converge to the same thing
this might be nomenclature question but
you're talking about how it's getting
the information from the future action
but you have to have already done that
action so why is it called state action
reward next state actions when it's
really the past one that you're updating
it's from what I'm understanding because
you're doing this one that he knew using
the information you learn to update the
one in the back so why is it why are we
were talking about it like it's a future
action it's the purpose of that is about
the particular terms used to define star
set I don't think it I mean I guess it's
really just that you have to wait till
you get that that last a is important so
that instead of saying that before what
we saw with TV learn ease you were in a
state action reward next state and then
you could update your cue function now
we're just saying you have to wait till
you've actually decided what to do in
that next state because that's how
you're choosing how to do update your
key function here that's what you're
plugging in for your target so in terms
of the convergent properties it requires
a couple of different things so if we
are we need sort of two things we're
gonna need the fact that we're how we're
updating our cue function and
it's gonna be updating incrementally and
so like what we talked about before
we're gonna meet some conditions over
the Alfa's if alpha is equal to one
generally your Q functions not going to
converge because it means you're not
remembering anything about the past if
alpha zero then you're not updating
anymore so generally you need something
in terms of those step sizes which
allows you to sort of slowly be
incrementally but still be converging so
these are one sufficient set of
conditions so if you have stuff like
alpha T is equal to one over T now
empirically often you're gonna want to
pick very different forms of learning
weights so alpha T is often referred to
as like the learning rate parameter and
empirically you're often not going to
want to use this generally not gonna use
this this is gonna a yeah here you're
often gonna want to use different things
empirically you can you end up using
sometimes small constants or slowly
decaying constants something that depend
on the domain but this is from a
theoretical side what is sufficient to
ensure convergence and then the other
aspect is that the way that your that
your policy itself has to satisfy the
condition of Glee which means that you
are sort of slowly getting more greedy
over the time but you're doing so in a
way that you're still sampling all state
action pair is an infinite number of
times now now I'm just know for a second
that that's not always possible like so
if you have a domain where I things are
not reachable after a point it's not or
ghatak you can't get back to certain
states after you get there let's say
you're flying a helicopter and you break
the helicopter so you can't get back up
there and then you're not gonna be able
to satisfy glee because at some point
you broke your helicopter and then like
you have no idea what it would have been
like if you continued to fly your
helicopter in the air so there can be
some domains for which it is very hard
to satisfy Klee um but we generally are
gonna ignore those even though there's
some really interesting work on how do
we deal with those cases as well in
those cases something you might assume
is that it's more of an episodic problem
so maybe you have like a hundred
helicopters and so when you crash one
that's considered a termination
condition and then you get out your next
one so you may or may not be able to be
reading in the limit of information in
the limit of infinite exploration there
that you can sort of have a balanced
amount of exploration and we're gonna
talk a lot more later about sort of how
to do this exploration in a much more
smart manner and in a way that gave us
finite sample guarantees on how much de
do we need to learn a good policy so
this just says what I said there before
which is you know we generally not going
to use the step size which is where you
have Q of s th t plus alpha the cost one
minus alpha times the so this is the
condition versa assuming that that
particular update of how we're updating
our key functions yeah so in the monte
carlo case we had sufficient condition
on which the height esata smelly bleep
like the Epsilon's
okay do we have anything similar in
general great question mission is about
it for the Monte Carlo do we have a
similar condition if you were just if
you're doing first visit that alone is
sufficient because you're getting an
unbiased estimator that's converging for
all of your returns so as long as you be
at all state action pairs an infinite
number of times
if you're doing it in this incremental
fashion then if you're if you're if
you're playing around with how that
alpha is then you need to have similar
conditions to make sure I guarantee how
do you know that condition 1 holds how
do you know that things are clean yeah
like a Monte Carlo we didn't have a
condition rate which was that epsilon
decay is one other question so there's
like how do you make sure something's
Glee one sufficient condition is that
epsilon is 1 over up it's 1 over T or
whatever I work like yeah oh you mean
like in terms of sufficient conditions
like this yes really
it'll be believed if and only if this
epsilon is go to zero but there's some
dead roaches or something like that yeah
I think it's priceless
and Robyn's mother a sequence like yours
turnip essentially you're very ensuring
us you're doing infinite number of
updates if it is amount of green or like
random exploration it's still it's going
down fast enough those in Virginia I
think it's probably exactly a thing but
I can touch ok so then when we get into
key learning which is related to the
question we just asked okay why are we
picking that particular action next why
don't we just pick the max yeah we could
just pick the max instead so sarsa is
picking this particular action next
q-learning
is picking the map section next it's not
so optimistic if you were a better
weighted so that we could mix are set
and q-learning you certainly could but
then that also made me realize maybe I
wasn't being clear enough for the
earlier part see Ashley can do better in
some domains early on particularly if
there's a lot of really negative rewards
because it's being realistic
in other cases q-learning will it be
better even early on because you could
you're being more optimistic and as we
talked about a little bit before often
optimism is really helpful for
exploration the cliff work example in
Sutton in Bartow is a case where some
actions lead the agent to like fall off
a cliff and so some actions are really
bad and so they're being optimistic
early on means that you're gonna take a
lot of really bad decisions and suffer a
lot of negative rewards for a while many
other domains they're not like that so
depends on I guess you could certainly
mix them all right so I guess in terms
of Q learning one thing that's
interesting here is so we can again sort
of think about how are we improving this
and we're gonna sort of be greedy with
respect to the current estimate at the
optimal Q and and really this is quite
similar to what we were doing in sarsa
except for now when we update this Q
we're really just going to be doing this
max so Q of s t-80 is going to be equal
to the previous value plus alpha word
plus max over a so now also note that
you can update this a little bit earlier
because you don't have to wait until the
next action it's taken
so you only need to observe this part
you don't need to actually see the next
section that's taken and then you can
perform policy improvement and in
general in this case you're only in it
you only need to update the policy for
the state that you were just in so you
can do PI you can update PI b4 st put
the action you just took you don't need
particularly large state spaces that can
be helpful so we actually ended up
talking about this a little bit already
about whether or not how you initialize
Q matters it doesn't asymptotically I
mean if you have a case where your Q
function is going to converge to the
right thing it'll still converge the
right thing no matter how you
initialized it I'm so if it satisfies
these other conditions but it certainly
matters a lot empirically and so even
though often we think of just
socializing randomly or initializing it
with zero initializing it optimistically
is often really helpful so we'll talk
more about that when we talk about
exploration in line six yeah max on it
hard max so now I'm if we do Q learning
um let's see I think well I'm gonna
leave this as just an exercise you can
do there but you could just do the exact
same exercise for Q learning and see how
these updates propagate so just like
Monte Carlo versus cute Monte Carlo
versus TD for policy evaluation there's
some of the same issues with Q learning
Q learning is only an update your Q
function for the state you were just in
so even if it turns out later in the
same episode you get a really high
reward you're not gonna back propagate
that information at the end of the
episode and the way that you would with
Monte Carlo so Q learning updates can be
much slower often than Monte Carlo just
like and so that has implications for
how quickly you can learn to make better
decisions so the conditions that are
sufficient to ensure that Q learning
with the greedy converges is basically
the same as SAR so we need to make sure
that things are that ugly
and actually and slightly revised this
so if you just want to make sure that
you converge then you need to visit all
sa infinitely often I need to have these
conditions on the alpha so if you look
at the same conditions in order for the
Q functions to converge you need to have
these conditions on how you're updating
your look like what your learning rates
are and that you visit all state action
pair is infinitely often but that just
isn't that sufficient to allow you to
converge the optimal Q values and then
if you want actually make sure that the
policy you're following is really the
optimal policy then you need to beegley
cuz you also need the policy you chose
to be more and more greedy all right let
me get just briefly into the
maximization bias before we finish the
maximization bias is an interesting
question so why are we going to talk
about this well okay let's go back to
this one so in Q learning what are we
doing Q learning we're computing the Q
function and then we're being in greedy
with respect to it now we're gonna need
some more data and we're reading our Q
function and we're being greedy with
respect to it and so we're in greedy
with respect to it and so we're always
sort of doing this dance between
updating stuff getting more evidence but
then trying to kind of exploit that
knowledge up to some random exploration
and the maximization bias points out
that maybe there can be some problems
with this okay so let's just consider a
particular example imagine there's a
single state MDP which means there's
only one state but there are two actions
and both of them actually have 0 mean
random rewards so now you can think of
these as being like gaussians right now
we're mostly talking about it when their
award is actually deterministic but it
doesn't have to be it could be a
stochastic reward but in this case we're
going to imagine that whether you take
action a1 or action a2 your expected
value is 0 but the value get on any
particular episode any particular step
might not be 0 might be you know 1 or
minus 1 or things like that
the average is still 0 but on any
particular step you could have something
different but the expected value is 0
and so the q value for both s a1 and the
q value for s a2 is 0 which is the same
the value these are all you know the
optimal Q and s values so let's imagine
that there's some prior samples you've
tried action a1 a bunch of times you
tried action a2 a bunch of times and you
compute an empirical estimate of this
and here again where there's just a
single state and we can just average
over these so let's imagine that it's
super simple that we have a gamma is
equal to zero so we're really just
estimating over the immediate reward
okay so there's no future rewards we're
just saying all the times that we've
tried this action before what we're all
the roids we get and we average and now
what we want to do is we want to take
our empirical estimates of the Q
function for a1 and a2 and we want to
figure out what the greedy policy is and
the problem is that can be biased so
even though each of these unbiased
estimators have Q or themselves even
though the two estimates of the actions
are biased when you take the max over it
it can be biased so let's just write out
what that is so RB I hat is equal to the
expected value of max over Q so I'm
gonna meticulous spectra over max of
these two things because that's how I
defined my policy my policy says pick
whichever of these to empirically looks
best but we know that from Jensen's this
is greater than equal to if you switch
the max and the expectation this is just
equal to max of 0 so the important part
is this so and this is equal to the true
be PI so that means that whatever we
compute can be a biased estimator of the
true be PI so why does this happen well
if you get a you know if you only have a
finite
of samples I if I have tried action a1 a
finite number of times it might be on
that finite number of times it happens
to look slightly positive
like it's like point zero 1 instead of 0
and then when I take my policy I'm gonna
maximize over those so I'm gonna
immediately exploit whichever one
happens to look better even if it was
just a school chance so that's why you
can get this maximization bias and the
same thing can happen in terms of MDPs
so the this generally can happen you can
also look at some nice examples from
this paper by John so that John says it
nicholas and shimon or where they show
how this can also happen in markov
decision processes where essentially if
you if your estimates for these cue
functions then you're going to be sort
of biased to whatever has happened to
look at in your data and so you can have
a maximization bias so one thing that
was proposed to try to handle deal with
this case is called double q-learning
and so the idea is instead of I having
one cue function or I have two different
cue functions and we're going to create
two independent unbiased estimators of Q
and you're gonna use one of them for
your decision-making and the other to
try to estimate the value and that's
going to allow us to have it unbiased
estimator and the reason that you might
want to do this is because then it
consider help help with this issue that
you can end up being overly biased
towards things that have happened to
look good yet now you're so separating
like between the samples that you're
good that you're getting to estimate how
good an action is versus the way you're
trying to estimate your policy so I'm
just gonna be a little brief with this
because of time q-learning basically
double Q learning basically means that
we're gonna have these two different Q
functions and then with 50% probability
we're gonna update 1 and 50% probability
we're gonna update the other so this
woods and in this case I'm gonna skip
I'll add this in the final slides I want
to show you the difference so the
difference here can be significant
so in this case this is sort of looking
at the percent of time that we're taking
bad actions in this domain where you
couldn't have in this case you have a
scenario where it's actually the wrong
thing to do but it's stochastic and so
with a small amount of data it can end
up looking better compared to another
option where the reward is deterministic
and actually better but has no
stochasticity and then q-learning can
suffer quite a lot from this
maximization bias if you're using the
same q function to essentially
immediately define your policy as you
are for estimating the value of that
policy whereas double Q learning does a
lot better in this case so it's
something to consider in terms of when
you're implementing these things and
it's pretty small overhead too because
you can just maintain two different q
functions all right and if that was a
little bit faster I'll make sure to put
details in there I when I we upload the
additional slides today the main things
that you should know them today is to be
able to understand how you do this Monte
Carlo on policy control and same for
sarsa and Q learning it's useful to
understand how quickly they update both
in terms of whether you have to wait to
the end of episode and then how quickly
information propagates back and then
also to understand how to define the
conditions on the algorithms converging
to the optimal q function
thanks